would you rather wear granny panties or  flats for the rest of your life  Flats I hate wearing anything with a  heel granny panties I cannot do Flats no  wait do Flats mean like can you just  like flat shoes oh I'm thinking ballet  slippers yeah more of just like shitty  shoes  ugly Flats granny panties my bad knees I  can't wear shitty shoes  comfortable  yeah I'm all poor gray pants not too  super  you're going to like a red carpet  Premiere granny panties are on I'll get  a poofy dress because I'm not wearing  flats no R.I.P to the bodysuits  no we can't we couldn't wear tight stuff  anymore but no that's fine we'll have  flies we rarely ever do